Dennis Scott Turner Sports NBA analyst
TNT exclusive coverage of the Eastern
Conference Finals as the Bucks and
Raptors tipping off tonight it's a
pivotal game five bucks and Raptors and
Dennis Scott one of the great shooters
in NBA history joins us what do you
think of Drake on the sidelines Dennis
laughs you guys I don't I don't really
have a problem with it with the way you
know the world is today social media is
this thing about it you know the Jack
Nicholson's of the world they've been
doing it so long so they're used to
being there I think is Drake's first
time or baby's second time or like we
said his his team's won yet so maybe
he's still trying to enjoy the moment
who do you remember being on the
sidelines when you were playing you
mentioned Jack Nicholson Nicholson never
say anything to you during a Lakers game
oh no question about it
Jack's early years he would speak to you
know hey Scott you missed a couple shots
tonight when you gonna make one you know
a little fun stuff like that but never
with back in the day any superstar or
celebrity go up and give me coach a
little massage will show to us who else
was on the sidelines back I know Spike
Lee was always there but yeah it was
always there first in Orlando it was
more like a lot of those baseball
players you know golfers you know a
young Tiger Woods you know guys like
that would be more of more sports
figures would be there in Orlando days
all right as far as this game coming up
tonight what's this hinge on well I
think the Bucs have to get back to being
who they are and I think all season long
has been inside out we honest and I know
people are you know just gonna sound
crazy I know people love the three like
I do but when yarnís dominates the paint
and makes the rappers play defense and
then it goes inside out and finds his
three-point shooters it seems like they
play better basketball that way and they
get into their defense they get out get
better stops and I've run would you
rather have giannis on your team or coin
ooh that's a great question right now
today I would probably say Yanis because
of what he's done and wouldn't shown us
all season long and I know collide this
year has reminded us how good of a
two-way player he is but I think right
now today I would probably go with the
honours I'm also wondering this though
dentist where you have Kawhi Leonard
we're not sure what he's doing after
this season but he probably looks around
in the playoffs although you know Lowry
has stepped up finally and probably says
gosh do I want to do this for the next
five years where I'm carrying another
team here do you think that you know
what's happened this year he's more
likely to stay in Toronto or less likely
I think he's more likely to stay I think
the bigger question we have to keep our
eye on is how it is relationships how
has his relationship with Masai Ujiri
you know progressed over the year how
well have they communicated because
that's probably the key if he stayed as
like Messiah
what are you telling Kawhi that you're
willing to add you're willing to let go
Ivan CC ahkam probably should get the
most improved players he award
how do you pay him and keep him have you
seen enough from Marc Gasol yet so it's
still a lot of basketball to be played
in my opinion it's Eastern Conference
and I think that will help in collage
decision Andre Iguodala Golden State
Warriors forward said that Steph Curry
is the second best point guard of all
time I mentioned that I can't put him in
that category because to me I don't
think we have point guards anymore I
just think you have guy like Steph is a
point guard his job is to get point so I
don't look at him as a point guard
dentist - you know I look a phenomenal
basketball player because to your point
and a lot of the GM's and I was a
basketball minds now say this his
position was basketball
he has such a unique skill being able to
shoot the basketball once he gets into
the parking lot and I think that's what
has anybody still messed up to this day
is when he's on the floor once he
crosses half-court he's in range you're
not used to teaching your defense to
pick up that far because
fundamental basketball says run back
protect the paint well Steph Curry
total opposite of that so I understand
what these without saying I understand
people are talking about the Magic
Johnson I their time as those two are
the one to know that's point guards ever
so that's why I to your question I don't
think we should put Steph Curry in a box
I think we should leave him alone and
let him continue to play and see where
it ends up who's had a bigger impact on
the game Michael Jordan or Steph Curry
ooh
now the game on the court not brand not
just just style of play now you post out
a play in their seed a little crazy when
you say style of play no question is
Steph Curry when you say impact it means
knocking off Michael George's do it in
the day and obviously I played in that
era so I still give Mike denied right
now today but but Dan and your listeners
Steph Curry still has a lot of
basketball left to play why are we still
trying to put him in a box let him loose
Steve Kerr has already shown us he puts
into work he's a still another game take
the stage take the stereotypes off and
just let him go and let's talk about
this five or six or seven years from now
and see what the numbers are talking to
Dennis Scott NBA TV covering the Bucs
and the Raptors that's a game five
coming up tonight at 8:30 also you look
at what Steph has been able to do
because you know kids small kids they
want to try to be Steph Curry and and
that's that's an impact like he's had a
global impact on the way the game is
played because everybody thinks they can
shoot not everybody thinks they can dunk
everybody thinks they can shoot that's
just a great point and that's what makes
it when you use the phrase style of play
because every person can go to a local
gym Recreation Center there's a driveway
and put up jump shots so I always
challenge people go to your driveway
today and walk you know a walk off a
free throw line
walk off a college three and let me see
you make it in the road and email me and
then do it the next day and the next day
the next day and then rain outside when
it's cold so it gives people a little a
better perspective on what the young man
doing he is knocking down shots from
range consistently night in and night
out and his teammates understand that so
that's why different in today's card as
you put it because when he is the ball
up he takes off running off 99 screens
and all of his teammates are looking to
get the ball and then would even get it
klay Thompson does it so when we have
two guys there are natural-born flame
throwers and it ran off screens and
their teammates no get them the
basketball and when in doubt will
support backdoor dark or backdoor layup
because that's the way the system is so
let's now put neither one of those guys
in a hole of it let them loose what it
bother you what's going on in the front
office of the Lakers if you are a free
agent and looking at the Lakers as a
possible landing site me personally yes
because I was a die-hard Magic Johnson
saying growing up so I'm on the other
side of the fence of the you know not
you know liking how magic you know came
out the other day and in the way he's
done it but I'm still a die-hard magic
fan I think he's earned the right to the
kind of figure if you're going to give
me this job and I'm supposed to have the
power let me do it my way
so I'm sure there's some others do you
know again when we listen to the story
seem like this maybe some more stuff and
they need to come out because I'm not
sure I'm not sure that we were done here
in the story you're there is there any
way that we look at Kevin Durant is
better than LeBron when it's all said
and done what would have to happen in
your mind where we would go you know
best players of all time and you start
to tick them off one two three four five
and then you get to LeBron and KD how
would you put him above LeBron it's for
me it's hard because your last phrase of
style of playing but there are two
styles of plays are so different where
it's hard to meet even to imagine you
know KD being a pants first guy k ds
from the time when he was playing a you
basketball back in DC ever ever he
played with my son he was always playing
up you know two years and he just always
been a natural-born scorer not like
Magic Johnson not like
you know you know sitting guys up he's
always been in the Michael Jordan Kobe
era of face of thinking of I might to
score as many buckets as I can and
that's who I am
and we've seen now since he's been in
gold state he has become a better passer
and a better defender who gave you more
grief Jordan or bird when you played
I think bird was probably the more
entertaining about it because because
Mike didn't really talk much trash
unless you made him mad and you know we
are we already know this the history of
45 verses 23 so don't bring that up then
I want you don't bring that up
[Laughter]
hey good to see you I'm about to catch
this ball on the block do a little pump
fake you didn't sound go to the
free-throw line it happens make one
free-throw make the second free-throw
you know me being a wild I rookie I told
Sam Vincent come down the court Scott
Skiles will come on screen catch it boom
make it three
alright good shot rook I'm gonna catch
the ball again I'm another pump fake
you're gonna reach forward and you're
gonna sit down I see you second quarter
I reach for it I get my second Fowler
goes today I go see second quarter so
that's how a more subtle Larry Barry was
so that was way more entertaining than
guys like calling out your name you were
saying you know different things Larry
was way more smooth with it but Mike
Mike if you got a man was coming after
you oh you got Mike mad the next thing
you looked up him to be 25 one year
Dennis average five point seven threes a
game attempts that was third most in the
league this season 45 players averaged
five point seven threes attempt in a
game or more man I don't know where
we're headed
Dennis but it feels like if you're not
shooting threes not making threes then
you're not keeping up with everybody
else well the only the only thing I say
to that day is make sure you're the
right guy taking those two
make sure you're put in the work daily
and it makes sure it's part of your
skill set sometimes you cannot force a
guy to go out there it's like a fish
being out of water but if a guy has
learned over the years become a decent
three-point shooter but knows how to mix
it up one beautiful things we saw the
other night on the road in Portland was
death Kerry putting the ball on the
floor getting to the rim
getting a reverse layup getting the
putback and then next thing you know and
he runs off six three oh I think he's
shown us that even a goddess takes what
the gun that he would took 16 threes he
still had four layups there so still be
able to mix it up to keep the defense
honest knowing that you still want to
take your number three tonight at your
best
how do you like your chances against
Steph Curry ooh my best we're doing if
we're doing a catch and shoot drill I
think I think I'm going neck-and-neck
with here we're doing anything off the
dribbles I'm drowning least you're
honest a dentist
great to catch up with you thank you for
joining us we appreciate your time
that's a Dennis Scott his nickname one
of the great nicknames 3d because he
shot threes I mean how good is that
he'll be covering game five Raptors
bucks that tips off tonight at 8:30
Eastern on TNT for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]